ever notice that when this country is at
its
weakest barack obama the former
president seems to appear out of nowhere
jetting in from martha's vineyard to
hawaii to make the country even weaker
and even more divided this week obama
appeared on television to tell us that
anyone who complains when their children
are taught in school that some races are
better than others
anyone who complains about that is the
bigot
what is going on here exactly there's a
hostility
at the bottom obviously of barack obama
that's interesting glenn beck is one of
the very few people who saw it early
from the very beginning
he's the host now the glenn beck radio
program we're honored to have him on
tonight glenn thanks so much
for joining us so i i thought of you
earlier this week because you had
a very clear picture of who obama was
underneath you felt the hostility
in him you said it people became
completely hysterical
but i thought that was that was a deep
insight that a lot of people missed
right but back then uh
tucker you couldn't call a president
racist
uh you know that back then that was
crazy now that we've gone through the
trump era i guess it's okay
here's the thing um i apologized for
saying that
about two years later um because it was
an artful uh i didn't i i was thinking
out loud
and i remember i was on fox and friends
and i said i think the president is a
racist no
that's not quite right i think he just
has a problem
with the white culture well that i mean
holy cow what do you mean by white
culture
i don't know marxist tell me now what
you mean by white culture
i didn't i i was uh not
versed on critical race theory i wasn't
versed
in the language of marxist now barack
obama i am
i take my apology back i was exactly
right and i even stated it right
you are a racist if you believe in
critical race theory
if you think that what dr martin luther
king said
that he envisions a country that uh is
is uh seeing seeing people for the
content of their character not their
color if you think that's wrong
then yes you are a racist if you believe
that critical race theory
which teaches children that white
is an incurable kind of disease
that you will never be able to not be
racist
that uh somehow or another you have to
be punished for the sins of the past
i know that goes to your critical race
theory barack obama
but i don't believe in that i'm sorry i
don't believe in that and i also don't
believe in collective
salvation which you do by the way you
rejected jeremiah wright how you feeling
about the new senator
uh from uh from georgia how do you feel
about him
i wonder i'll bet you you love him but i
bet you don't have the courage to
say it that is such a good point
you felt that there's a hostility
there's an anger there a
meanness underneath obama watched him
really closely
all these a hatred and i could always
kind of feel it it's very obvious
now i'm sure that you saying this out
loud
will you know bring another tidal wave
of of rage but it's because you're
telling the truth
yeah look i'm tired of of towing the
line
i'm tired of especially the marxist i
was called a racist for calling him a
marxist
he is a marxist if you believe in
critical race theory there's no science
behind it
it is a marxist theory meant
to divide people and destroy a country
well what are we doing his wife even
said
brock knows we're gonna have to change
our language the way we talk to each
other we're gonna have to train
change our traditions well that's
exactly what
we're doing and he said this week that
uh
joe biden is just finishing the job he
started
well that job is the fundamental
transformation of america
and barack thinks that it's oh well it's
all about the economy and they're
thinking about
losing their position losing my position
i don't care
i want my children to have freedom
i want my children to be able to make a
choice on what they do
how they live where they live i will
not be silenced by a bunch of marxists
and barack obama you don't have the
courage
you have too much hillary clinton in you
that's why people didn't like
you the second term because hillary
clinton
she just puts you down a shoot
glenn beck thank you for that it's great
to see you tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else